hello welcome to the Benjamin and
Barbara Zucker lecture series at Yale's
program for the study of anti-Semitism
my name is Alice Kaplan I'm the director
of the Whitney Humanities Center and a
member of The Advisory Board of yipsa
I'm delighted to welcome Julie elsky
associate professor in the department of
modern languages and literatures at
Loyola University Chicago it's a special
pleasure to welcome Julie back to Yale
she completed her PhD in French in 2014
and since then her accomplishments in
the Twin areas of Jewish studies and
French Studies have been remarkable
in 2020 she published writing occupation
Jewish Emma Gray voices in Wartime
France with Stanford University presses
series on Jewish history and culture and
you'll see a link to the book uh under
chats
this book studies how Jewish emigry
writers re-examine both their jewishness
and their places authors writing and
Publishing or not publishing in France
during the occupation
her talk this afternoon is drawn in
large part from research conducted at
the United States Holocaust Memorial
Museum
Julie has published articles on World
War II and its Legacy as well as on
Jewish identity in France in pmla Yale
French studies
and other journals she's the recipient
of Grants and fellowships too numerous
to name she's contributed to the
Holocaust Museum's Digital Collection of
objects of memory called experiencing
history we're also putting that on the
chat it's really a fascinating uh
digital experience clicking on that link
please keep an eye out for two of her
current projects both of them
co-authored uh one called undesirables
in France German Jewish women artists
and intellectuals during the Holocaust
and still in the planning stages a
museum exhibit on the Flight of the
avant-garde through wartime Marseille
and finally julielski's new book project
is about the origins of the theater of
the Absurd during the second world war
with a focus on
enesco's inner war and wartime
experiences today she will speak to us
about a Jewish poet Poetics of Exile
Benjamin fondan and Jewish Emma Gray
writers in occupied France please submit
questions as we go uh in the Q a Julie
will speak for about 40 minutes and then
we'll open it up for discussion
hello
um I hope this is working now with me
speaking
um I would like to thank ipsa for
inviting me especially Alice Kaplan and
Maury Samuels it's really a true honor
to speak at Yale where I did my PhD in
French and where I began the project
um from which I'm drawing my research
for my talk today uh with the generous
guidance of Alice Kaplan and much
support from Maurice Samuels and this
work would really not be possible
without your intellectual and personal
generosity Alice
in my talk today I will first discuss
the historical context of Jewish Eastern
European immigrant immigrants to France
in the interwar period and then their
experiences under the Nazi occupation of
France I'll then turn to the question of
how two Jewish writers change their
approaches to writing in French in
response to the persecutions of the Jews
in France
so the the title of my talk focused on
Fondant but actually I really should
have said it's about fundan and one
other writers
first I'll talk about the polish-born
novelist Jean maleke to think about the
question of anti-Semitic representations
of Jewish voice and speech
and then second I will address the
romanian-born poet and philosopher
Benjamin fundan and his representation
of a sense of Exile under the occupation
one of the main points that I want to
make today is that Jewish immigrant
writers did not stop thinking about
their place in France and as French
writers at the moment of the June 1940
defeat
the start of the occupation did not
Usher in their silence in fact this
period has often been overlooked in
studies of European francophony as and
even in studies of Jewish writers in
France and by European francophony I'm
referring to non-french European writers
who wrote in French whether or not they
immigrated to France
but I argue that the period of the
occupation is a crucial period of study
and it was precisely under the
occupation that these authors addressed
the choice to write in French and faced
anti-Semitism in new ways
and Benjamin fondan were among a number
of writers who came to France in their
teens and 20s in the interwar period And
I want to share
sorry um so these are some of the
writers I've studied they came to France
and mostly settled in Paris to become
French writers in a country that
represented universalism and Jewish
civil rights
they also wanted to be part of a major
literary Center
the period after World War one saw the
largest wave of Jewish immigration and
French history one that radically
transformed the landscape of French
jewry
and I have some
facts and figures here but by 1940 of
approximately 330
000 Jews in France 140 000 were
immigrants without French citizenship
and 55 000 were naturalized and you
could see
um by the by 1926 six percent of the
population of France or immigrants
Jewish and non-jewish and I noted an
important law from August 10 1927 that
eased requirements for
um for naturalization and this will
become important again under the
occupation
so I'll give a little bit of context
about the experience of the occupation
by Jewish immigrants from Eastern Europe
in particular and focusing on two
aspects the June 1940 civilian flight
from Paris
um the lights just went off here I'm
sorry well okay they turned back on
um
um sorry the focusing on the June 1940
civilian flight from Paris called the
exode or Exodus and then life under the
occupation living with the threat of
arrest and deportation
in June 1940 just before the German
forces entered Paris and just before
France signed an Armistice that divided
the country in half
um into a Southern and a northern Zone
there was a massive civilian flight
Southward called The Exodus I mentioned
paris's population dropped from almost 3
million people to between 700 000 and 1
million people in a matter of weeks this
major city was emptied Scholars estimate
that the roads of France were flooded
with between uh with around 6 million
people or one-sixth of the population
the country and 2 million belgians and
luxemburgers Iran namorovsky famously
depicted this flight in her novel sweet
Pon says that was rediscovered in the
early 2000s and Benjamin fondant also
represented it Emma Gray authors were in
a unique position in June 1940 as they
were fleeing in a country to which they
had immigrated
Shannon Fogg has written extensively
about how the Exodus forced people to
rely even more on individual social
structures and networks for survival and
emigree writers indeed often relied on
their intellectual networks and this was
not always possible for other Jewish
immigrants in France
as people doubly displaced from home
Emma Gray writers were particularly in
tune with the notion of Exile and this
perhaps explains why they wrote during
the war about the events of June 1940 in
far greater numbers than their
french-born colleagues
aside from emigrate authors fictional
texts there are surprisingly few
literary depictions of The Exodus that
were written during the war although
there do exist many journalistic
accounts
whether in the occupied or Southern
zones Jewish immigrants were subject to
anti-semitic and xenophobic legislation
and were threatened with internment and
deportation as historian Patrick Vale
argues there was no clear division
between anti-semitic and xenophobic laws
under the occupation rather they were
interwoven and even competed with each
other
from the beginning of the occupation the
vulnerable status of Jewish refugees and
recently naturalized Jewish French
citizens was at the center of legal
changes in government action the law of
August 10 1927 that I mentioned earlier
eased requirements for naturalization
was used as a negative symbol of the
supposed degradation of France and it
became a vehicle for denying immigrants
the right to belong as French citizens
over fifteen thousand French people
were denaturalized and 110 000 Algerian
Jews lost their citizenship
Vichy passed anti-semitic Jewish
statutes in October 1940 and June 1941
and they indicate where the bottom of
this slide
um a day after the first Jewish statutes
utter law was passed that allowed for
the internment of foreign Jews
after the defeat foreign Jews were the
first to be rounded up in Paris in the
spring and summer of 1941
approximately 3 000 foreign-born Jews
died in French internment camps early in
the occupation
with the collaboration of Vichy Jewish
foreign refugees and French internment
camps were deported Eastward in the
first convoys from the southern Zone in
August 1942 to concentration camps so
I'm giving these numbers just to
indicate that they were the often the
first wave of victims of deportations
the very tragic uh tragically famous
valdive Roundup of July 1942 targeted
almost 30 000 people who were stateless
or unnaturalized immigrants Jewish
immigrants from Germany Austria Poland
Czechoslovakia and the Soviet Union
by the end of the war only three percent
of Jewish people deported from France
returned 75 of Jews in France survived
um and you know this is a uh
a number that's often uh in the news and
it's important to think about and also
to be careful about it but when you
break it down 90 of French Jews survived
compared to 60 of foreign Jews
so I'm gonna stop sharing for a moment
even though I'll share again
um under the occupation numerous Jewish
immigrant authors responded to
anti-Semitism in new ways especially
with regard to the French language these
authors conceived of their position as
Jewish immigrants through writing itself
during the war and just as they were
rejected from France as immigrants and
as Jews or in reaction to this double
rejection as immigrants and as Jews
why do I focus on the question of French
language
first the language question is
implicated in the politics of
assimilation and integration including
in citizenship law and across the
political Spectrum this was the case
During the interwar period and under
Vichy in the interwar period as Nick
Underwood has shown in his exciting new
book Yiddish Paris French language
lessons were an important part of the
cultural activities of Yiddish
organizations looking at the topic of
language and integration from a totally
different angle the demographer
published a study of immigration in
France 19 in 1932 based on racial
classifications
The Scholar Patrick van who I mentioned
earlier has done a lot of work on
that's m-a-u-c-o refers to language as
one of the main or the major factors of
assimilation he argues based on a
so-called fact that Slavic immigrants
cannot Master the French language which
is obviously not true but his argument
is that
um he argues that they are never going
to be able to assimilate and his
conclusions were actually accepted on
the left and on the far right uh During
the interwar period
Marco would be considered one of the
major Specialists on immigration under
Vichy when he wrote anti-semitic texts
one month after the start of the
occupation the ministry of Justice
sought to create a new nationality code
and in this code a criteria would be
speaking and understanding French
and it should be noted that Vichy never
succeeded in creating their new
nationality code
the second reason for focusing on
language is that many Jewish immigrant
writers responded in their literature
and in their writing in French to a
specific current of xenophobic in the
xenophobic press of the far right
the far right featured anti-semitic and
xenophobic representations of Jewish
language and accent as the evidence of
the impossibility of including Jews and
Jewish immigrants in the nation
this attitude goes back to La France
or Jewish France written by the
journalist Edward in 1886 and it
continues in the occupation
a foundational text of French
anti-Semitism in the 19th century
declares that Jews cannot really speak
French because they cannot truly think
like French people
even claims that one can recognize a
Jewish person from their pronunciation
and their accent in French and from
um I'm using his terms he says there's
no difference between an Alsatian Jew
and an immigrant from the leban
a particularly interesting example of an
article from the occupation draws on
Jewish language among refugees in
Marseille
and as I mentioned there's a major
civilian flight from Paris Southward and
Marseille became a new center of
intellectual life during the war French
and Refugee artists from around Europe
congregated there as they waited for
visas to leave and I'm excited to be
working more on this aspect
um of marseille's History
with
um with my colleague Alyssa Shapiro from
the Viewpoint of the far right the
Panorama of Accents in 1940s Marseille
we can think of you know there's a lot
of writing about the cafes that ReSound
with the accents of refugees
um you find that representation both
among refugees themselves and in the far
right
but from the from the view point of view
of the far right these accents that you
could hear were the sign of racial
Corruption of the French city
let me share again
um
okay
the anti-semitic collaborationist
writers
describes the city in his article
marcelia or Marseille the Jew which he
published in the collaborationist
newspapers
Marseille appeared to him to be
dominated by Jewish immigrants from
Eastern and Central Europe one of the
defining features of the new Jewish
presence is their language and if Abate
generalizes it as Yiddish
um which isn't necessarily the case but
the way he writes about it is that it's
all Yiddish and foreign
Jewish language is a violent assault on
the calm evenings of the Terrace and I
uh the the cafe Terrace and I have some
quotes here cocktail hours now Jew hour
when he hears a Jewish person talking he
says he spits out some words in Yiddish
um as for other Jewish people
frequenting the cafes he writes Yiddish
explodes on their tongues their
claw-like hands wave around as high as
their ears
writes that the Polish and Czech Jews in
the cafes seem to be conventional
but far from veril and his
representation middle-aged Bourgeois men
but their language gives them away he
says uh they're comfortably Bourgeois in
their Grace suits but with their
Sinister mugs of featherless owls
largely past their 50s gibbering in
their violidish which resembles German
mangled by a CD so not only does single
out Jewish difference but he also
conflates it's a really interesting
quote he conflates the Jew and the Arab
for Sidi is a a derogatory term for a
North African an appropriation of the
Arab honorific
so the Jew is like an Arab trying to
speak German
as Sandrine sanos writes in her book The
Aesthetics of hate far-right
intellectuals anti-Semitism and gender
in 1930s France
um and I'm quoting from her Colonial
racism and anti-Semitism were imbricated
rather than parallel in this far right
discourse
article is in fact a prime example of
what sanos describes as Joseph's
approach in the 1930s that again I'm
quoting her promoted a racialized
frenchness whose boundaries were mapped
through the simultaneous and necessary
subjection of colonized subjects abroad
in the Empire which allowed the
denunciation and verbal persecution of
French Jews within the nation and these
boundaries of the French Nation were
conceived of in terms of anxieties about
masculinity and the exclusion based on
racial and sexual difference
in his article on Marseille say here's
the male Jewish Refugee accents or what
he refers reduces to Yiddish accents on
the cafe Terrace of Marseille as a
threat to the boundaries of pure French
and thus of a nation whose greatness
must be upheld through Empire
it is a sign of an unchangeable and in
assimilable in assimilable Jewish
otherness
and in the context of the war
um I want to mention that accents are
particularly fraught for example
speaking in what would be thought of as
a foreign Jewish accent would expose you
as a refugee
um and thus expose you to the threat of
deportation
racist and xenophobic ideas about Jewish
accents were not new to the period of
the occupation sander Gilman argues that
The Stereotype of quote the Jew who
sounds Jewish or too Jewish stands for
the Jew who unmasks himself for herself
as quote possessing all languages or no
language of his or her own and as such
is inherently different and corrupt
in a xenophobic and anti-semitic book
published in 1939 Lagonda young the
author Sanjay O'Malley entitles a
chapter Liberty Gomez as I note here on
the PowerPoint
um and in this chat this chapter is
about how Jews and foreigners are taking
over
um small shops in France and this title
is a character of Jewish voice
um the this is like how the way in
French
um you have this kind of mocking of the
Jewish voice and we see this same the B
and the g in other texts including in
Balzac's novels as Maury Samuels has
written about and it's important to
think about these continuities in the
discourses of Jewish voice and
anti-Semitism and anti-semitic
representations of Jewish voice to take
into account how the writers respond to
this in the intour period and during the
war because I don't want to just Bracken
off the years of the the occupation in
1948-1944 as if it's this closed off
time but it's rather part of a
continuous time in the lives of these
writers
so I'll finally get to Jean maleke Jean
Malachi is the and I'll maybe stop
sharing my screen for a moment is the
pen name of Vladimir Malaki a
polish-born novelist who came to France
in the 1920s while he was working as a
stock boy in Leal he the the food policy
began to write and under Andrea's
mentorship he wrote
just translated as the men from nowhere
about miners in France miners as in
people who work in mines
ER he won the 1939 plea Ronaldo literary
award for this novel and after the
French defeat Malachi fled to the
southern Zone he survived with the help
of writers and editors who were now
based in the south of France and
eventually he moved to Marseille and
joined its world of intellectual
refugees
during the war he began to engage with
the idea of Jewish language and Jewish
characters in his novel planet
or world without Visa
and so this is an example of a kind of
shift in writing he really begins to
write about Jewish voice during the war
he wrote world without Visa over the
course of five years from 1942 while he
was waiting for a Visa in Marseille to
1947 when he was living in Mexico and he
was able to get out of France with the
aid of Varian fries uh famous emergency
rescue committee
his novel presents a world of refugees
in the on the 10th atmosphere
of Marseille under Vichy rule prior to
the nazia invasion of the Southern Zone
in November 1942.
in world without visas multilingual
Society of refugees Malachi reclaims and
valorizes what was mocked in the
anti-semitic press both the use of
Yiddish and Jewish Refugee axons
as as I showed in the article Mercedes
Malachi's wartime Diaries indicate that
even when he was in Mexico he was
Consulting the newspaper that published
Luciano's article and it's reasonable to
conclude that he was familiar with this
kind of discourse
the first third of Malachi's almost 700
page novel recounts The increasingly
tense days
um leading up to a large roundup of Jews
in Marseille culminating in the arrest
of the crowds family so this is a group
of characters in the novel and in
crucial scenes Malachi draws out the
anxieties and emotions of Jewish
language in direct opposition to its
portrayal by the far right
as racial contamination of France
and here I'm going to talk about an
example of Yiddish in the text
the reader first encounters the
characters Pavel and Sonia Crowns who
are Jewish refugees from Poland on the
day before their arrest
they are in conversation with Gustav or
Hirsch in English Hersh is a French Jew
who has lost a son in Dunkirk and
another son was being has been taken
prisoner by the Nazis his father is
interned in the Tennessee Camp outside
of Paris and he now sees himself as the
last of the line of the French hershas
the narrator specifies that this group
is speaking in French which is the only
language that Hersh understands but the
conversation unexpectedly turns to
Yiddish and it reveals anxieties about
Jewish bilingualism
so in this case bilingualism of uh
Yiddish and another language
Sonia crowns's
um hold on her sanity has been slipping
over the course of uh the conversation
as she fears the worst for her family
and as the group is discussing exit
strategies and visas Hersh begins to
laugh hysterically and Sonia yells in
his face and screams that she wants to
know what what he knows and isn't
telling her and amid all the anger and
the tension and fear and Hirsch's
laughter they kiss and Pavel her husband
begins to curse first in Polish then in
German then in Yiddish and
um the Yiddish is actually represented
in the text
um
interestingly
um in French not in Yiddish but he's
supposed to be speaking Yiddish so it's
an interesting thing that happens here
and I have a couple of examples of black
ear in your guts and it's not a typo in
the text the the words are all linked
together
um
so this is Pavel speaking at first and
then this scene then indicates anxieties
about Yiddish speech during the war
because Hersh is provoked by pavel's
outbursts in Yiddish and he says he
hears him muttering his revolting
incantations
um Pavel is Antonius Psalms and we find
this long Reflection by Hirsch it's
actually free indirect discourse so it's
as if the narrator is in the mind of
Hersh
and I'll read it was because of him him
being Pavel so Hershey's thinking about
pavel's use of Yiddish it was because of
him that France was no longer France and
life no longer fit to be to live
Hersh was not an anti-summite how could
he be feeling so little that he was a
Jew so not at all Jewish
and her she tell keeps telling himself
that he cannot be anti-semitic he
obviously hates anti-semites and yet the
sight of these Eastern European Jews
fill him fills him with rage
he says other than any ref in reference
to the Dreyfus Affair he'd never heard
the word reef or Jew in France until
Eastern European Jews came in
Hirsch doesn't understand Yiddish but
just hearing it does something to him
and what begins as this terrible
condemnation he goes on and on above
Eastern European immigrant Jews ends
with sympathy and love for her soon sees
that he doesn't believe any of the
horrible things he's thinking of the
immigrants and he realizes he's just
scared out of his mind
um but this Yiddish and his perception
of its rhythm of incantation brings out
his own anxieties about his rejection
from French Life as a Jew
Hersh gives voice to the feet to the
fear in response to anti-semitic
representations of Jewish language as
the central theme of their exclusion
from the nation
um another another example is
um thinking about accent so I spoke
about Yiddish in the book and now like
to think about how Malachi responds to
um Accents in the anti-semitic press and
I would say it's a kind of form of a
reappropriation or reclaiming these
accents uh he uses the same belittled
speech but now against racial discourse
about accents so um we have another
character named Raya Bergman who you see
in the first line she's
thinking she just had a dental procedure
she she's Jewish we know that and she's
had a dental procedure and she is just
speaking with S's and Z's and shows this
I'm giving you the excuse me English
translation
sorry
the the French would be B's and D's
um
and so it's kind of a joke because she
had a dental procedure and that's why
she's speaking in the way that you would
normally associate with the stereotypes
of Jewish voice but actually Malachi
um revised the novel
which was originally published in 1947
he revised it in the 90s right before he
died for a republication and he changed
the scene so that we first meet Raya and
she's just speaking in this accent um
that would normally seem like a
stereotypical Jewish accent and I
provided the quotes here
and then as it goes on you realize she's
only speaking that way because she had a
dental procedure but you still think you
know he says the the dentist said that
her good old diction would come back and
you think oh she probably doesn't have
what he with this French dentist would
think of as good Jewish diction but then
you learn more about her and you realize
that she's actually from Brittany and so
in this scene Malachi is kind of playing
with our assumptions or breaking our
assumptions of Jewish accent
um to make a kind of joke about it here
and he's disrupting a category that at
the time left no room for disruption
um he's uh he's doing this in the face
of anti-Semitic writings in which
language cannot surprise us but instead
is supposed to be a defining aspect of
race so these are just some examples I'm
giving you of how Malachi kind of takes
anti-semitic discourse about Jewish
speech and turns it on its head
so I I'd like to finally um go to
another author Benjamin fondan there's a
great Photograph by Man Ray
um that I wanted to share
um and I want to look at his portrayal
of displacement and Exile
um under the fear of arrest and the
threat of deportation fondant was a
romanian-born poet and philosopher who
immigrated to France in 1923. he was
already an active member of the Romanian
literary avant-garde and Bucharest
before he emigrated
he became a French citizen in 1938 and
was mobilized into the French infantry
and served in what has been called the
phony War he was taken prisoner by the
Nazis in the Loire region
um in June 1940 just a few days before
the Armistice after he escaped he found
himself on the roads in France during
the civilian flight that I described
before and then he was hospitalized in
the Val de gras Military Hospital in
Paris for appendicitis he spent the
occupation living in semi-hiding in
Paris where he refused to wear the
yellow star and he continued to write
for a time in the literary journal
which was based in Marseille and which
helped him out when he needed to find a
place to live in Marseille and I wanted
to share a really amazing postcard that
he wrote to jean-palar who was the
editor of Callie dusud
um he wrote this in October 1940 and on
the postcard he expressed his intention
to continue publishing Bala was actually
instrumental in helping get it to get
fund on citizenship before the war and
fondant turns this postcard into a
creative text it's the censored wartime
card with simple fill in the blank lines
used by soldiers to communicate briefly
about their welfare with their families
but
um early on you can see uh Legends
so you're supposed to be speaking about
uh these words mean killed prisoner
deceased and here fondant kind of turns
it into a different text and he says
have not been killed I remain their
prisoner of philosophy not deceased
so fondant bends the center the censored
rigid words on the postcard into a
literary text and likewise he would
continue to write within the censored
language of French to express his
experience under the occupation writing
a poetic vision of Exile
Sundown is a particularly interesting
case for thinking about how authors
change their approaches to writing and
how they responded to their position in
France under the occupation and I say
that because you revised most of his
poetry much of it already published
during the war and he left these
revisions behind with his wife who
survived him and he reorganized his
poems into a collection called lumalde
Phantom which could be translated as the
ACA Phantoms or maybe a plan words of Le
Mal De Pere which means homesickness so
maybe homesickness of phantoms and it
was first published in the 60s and is
only now really being translated into
English
the multiple manuscript versions of Le
Maldives are House of the archive
bibliotech literature Jacques to say in
Paris and these archival materials
really bring to life the way fondant was
questioning and reworking his ideas and
thinking about Exile in particular
and at this point I would like to focus
on one very long poem that fondant
revised during the war
ulis or Ulysses and he began it in 1929
when he was in Argentina working on a
surrealist film project but he finished
and published the poem in 1933.
already in the interwar version of the
poem fondant creates a Jewish Ulysses on
a 20th century Voyage to America to the
Americas actually and beyond always in
Exile and he's accompanied by immigrants
who are displaced after World War one
and in the wake of pogroms
Fontan marked up the 1933 edition of UDS
published by Cairo de poet making
revisions in the 1940s by hands on its
published Pages writing out new pages
and typing out new sheets of poems and
this archival object really shows the
shifts in his writing on the title page
he crossed out the date of publication
and changed it to 1944 he updated his
list of published Works he crossed out
the name of the publisher and on a
different page
um than from here that I don't have an
image of he replaced he creates his own
invented press name called Edison phone
or no end Editions as if to indicate
that his writing would be interrupted or
that he found a sense of completion
as a Jewish writer fundan was now cut
off from literary life and occupied
Paris because it was illegal for him to
publish
in his unpublished afterward
um to release he explains his motivation
to rewrite his poetry in the 1940s and
his current position in Francis at the
heart of this decision
the second version of you he's our
Ulysses is being shaped day by day it is
not yet finished by a man who has just
barely returned from a prisoner of war
camp and from the hospital and whom the
police are tracking at every
intersection to throw him in a
concentration camp and he actually
crosses out to throw him in a
concentration camp
and this Erasure of the disclosure of
his ultimate fear or the ultimate fear
of being sent to a concentration camp is
a kind of self-censorship on a note that
would never even be published and in
fact he wonders if his poem will ever be
finished or if he'll be interrupted
and afterward he typed up for the final
version of the poem exod The Exodus
might further explain his situation he
wrote that although he could not publish
at the time books search for friends
rather than a public and he kind of ends
it saying that he
um he ends it with a line that's often
used in resistance pamphlets which is he
asks the reader to take the cop the
trouble to recopy or have recopied
um his text so since he could no longer
publish openly as he had done before the
war fondon creates his own edition of
his poem
yeah
and I can show one particularly telling
change
um that has that has been studied uh
before especially by Monique has written
a lot about fundan
um in 1933 he has a line a Jew naturally
and yet Ulysses and then he changed in
the 40s to a Jew naturally you were a
Jew Ulysses and so jewishness is no
longer a coincidence but rather a
natural part of the condition of
traveling and displacement
so maybe uh in the few moments we have
I'm sorry I'm a couple of minutes over
but I wanted to look at uh the poem leg
Zone and it's a long poem that's a cycle
of dramatic dialogues and he added a
whole section during the war about the
June 1940 um defeat and civilian flight
the poem is about the cycles of Exile
throughout history and he represents
each with a river the Nile for Jewish
enslavements in Egypt the Rivers of
Babylon or the shores of Babylon for the
destruction of the second temple and the
Exile from Jerusalem and finally the sen
for the June 1940 civilian flight and
the pond takes its Central imagery from
Psalm 137 about the lamentation of the
Jewish people after The Siege of
Jerusalem I won't read it but this
repeats throughout the poem
and by using this Psalm fondant
assimilates the 1940 exode into a
recurring history of Exile and in so
doing he compares the Exile of the Jews
after the second the destruction of the
second temple in Jerusalem to The Exodus
from Paris and a kind of Destruction of
a lost Zion uh and a paradise for
immigrant off Jewish American Authors
there's another section that makes this
quite clear he transforms the famous
line from Psalm 137
um if I forget you owe Jerusalem he says
we were leaving Paris behind us If Ever
I forget you Jerusalem
and uh
Fontana also addresses a linguistic pain
associated with Exile and that's
forgetting your own language and being
displaced in a new language so at the
moment of leaving Paris Jerusalem the
speaker exclaims that he gets on his
knees and sobs in this language that he
forgets but that he remembers and you
see he has transliterated Hebrew here
and this is the words from the Shema
prayer the most you know fundamentally
important prayer for Jews a declaration
of unity with God and so Hebrew here is
transliterated in the text and it's
interesting to note he makes a mistake
actually in the Hebrew as kind of this
memory of the prayer for him
so throughout the poem phonon expresses
uh the complexity of losing France after
the defeat of losing his position in
France um a double loss of home
um as a as a Jewish immigrant and as a
writer because he's lost his position as
a writer and France or his ability to
publish anymore
so I'll just come to a conclusion now
um and say a little bit what happened to
these two writers fondan
um was was a very tragically deported to
auschwitzi in 1944 and he died just a
few weeks after the liberation of France
that year
his archives are
um as I said in Paris and they are you
can look at them in a room that
overlooks the pantheon a kind of Temple
a secular Temple to the great men and
women of France and there's actually a
plaque um in the pantheon about writers
who died in the war and his name is
included
and as I mentioned Malachi was able to
get to Mexico and he eventually came to
America and became an American citizen
he had a Guggenheim fellowship and did a
PhD in comparative literature I believe
so these two writers had completely
different paths from politics they
didn't know each other but they kind of
fill a gap in what Jewish writers were
thinking about and writing about during
the war itself I didn't have so much of
a chance to engage with fondant's
multilingualism and his poetry but both
authors were very interested in French
language and accent and transliteration
of other languages how how to break down
the barrier between French and other
languages
um they were both very engaged with
revisions as I said Malachi revised his
book just before his death so he was
thinking about this into the end of his
life and fundan revised his poetry
during the war so
um
you know can I'm happy I'm happy to
continue the conversation in Q a and
thank you so much
Julie thank you that was just such a
double pleasure that your sense of the
material world both the materiality of
language
words and also these amazing archival
documents that you put on the PowerPoint
I mean the postcard that he does a
detour them all you know recreates it as
a literary text that's amazing I've
never seen anything like that they're
both very appealing characters yeah yeah
I guess my first question for you is
about accents because I think it so your
analysis is so powerful one of the
things I was thinking looking at the uh
representations of the Jewish accent is
there was a problem in occupied France
which is that the Jew the Yiddish accent
sounds just like the German accent so
presumably all these Nazis would also
have had that made those same
you know they you would have been
imitated exactly the same way so that
this French nationalism had to somehow
embrace you know on the right had to
embrace Nazism
and still mock
um
I and I wonder if that's the reason why
umate refers to it as Yiddish accents
because actually most of these people in
the cafes they're not speaking Yiddish
almost they're speaking German with each
other a lot of them and so maybe that's
why he has to make it that they're
speaking Yiddish that they can't be
speaking uh German
um and Malachi does uh funny things too
where I mean he he shows that all of
these refugees have all kinds of
different accents but he also shows that
the Germans have accents he also uh
shows that there are all these Parisian
French Jews and they're they're
confronting the southern French accents
and he's kind of showing how everyone
has an accent there isn't this native
French accent yeah I think there's
something very important in what you're
saying about
we need to reconceive of accents I mean
you and I knew know that our field was
absolutely reactionary on the question
of accents there was only one way to
speak French yeah and having the wrong
accent could deny you tenure I mean I
mean yeah but there was something about
that and the other thing you said I
thought was very wise was that for the
anti-semites
the question of accent it wasn't an
there was only one kind of accent I mean
it was it meant that language was
completely predictable right right
that it was just racially defined
somehow and right that it was like you'd
either say you'd either say it with the
G or the P or whatever or you'd say it
in the right way right right and I guess
what you're showing about Monica and
fondant is that they really made
language unpredictable in every way hmm
yeah the thank you yes fondant was
really in his poem also shows that there
isn't just this
one monolingual language
um I there are other parts of his poems
where he does all kinds of interesting
things with language the character the
the speaker you know says he's speaking
the my language but I don't understand
it or they speak other people are
speaking his language and he doesn't
understand it and this kind of uh
breakdown of what
monolingualism is as definitely would do
many years later but already in his
poems I think he's doing this kind of
trying to get away from the idea of
French as this one monolingual language
with these barriers that keep everyone
out French has gotten more interesting
for sure I I was struck when you quoted
the translations from planets on Visa
they were using English for the Yiddish
but just
it's changing the spelling a little to
make it non-standard so in 1947 at
double day in New York they didn't want
to reproduce Yiddish words in an English
language text well actually I am the
French did they in the French no in
French also he doesn't and I think it
um
no it's like um
it's really interesting because
it's a
do this where they have characters
they're just it's just in French but
you're meant to understand that they're
not speaking French and it's really
interesting to think about how they
how they represent other languages and
yeah yeah and I don't know if it's that
Malachi and
it would be interesting to think like
perhaps Malachi really wouldn't have
fully been able to write that in Yiddish
and so it's interesting to think about
what it means this is something that
more contemporary writers in France have
talked about uh writing in Yiddish in
French
um and
um also actually a lot of different
contemporary writers have talked about
this idea in America also
um I mean it's how you signify another
language within the language I guess
right right is there an expression like
oh fancy don't text or online text yes
yeah yeah
um we have a few more minutes if there's
some questions if there aren't more
questions you and I could go on talking
forever
let me ask you a question really on
behalf of one of our students who's
starting to work on Malachi and Norman
mailer because that was a very enabling
friendship for my for both of them
really you know the American and this
guy who you know I guess it was Varian
Frye who got him to Mexico into the U.S
is that how he got he that's right
and what do you think Norman mailer
learned from Malachi's multi-linguism I
mean certainly we don't associate mailer
with that kind of language play yeah
that's interesting
I don't know if I have a really good
answer the the what I have heard uh
between my because uh Malachi translated
a text by Norman mailer
um but I have
um
seen one kind of discuss film discussion
between the two authors and they were
especially talking about politics
because Malachi was a I didn't have a
chance to really get into this but he
was a very committed trotskyist and so
Mexico was the right place right yeah
and uh and so they they're talking a lot
about that and
um
uh I was was saying how he you know he
never uh
compromise himself in any way and he was
very staunch in his in his support so I
what stands out to me more um is their
conversation about politics I must say
but it is really interesting to think
about the connection between these you
certainly think of mailer as a super New
Yorker and yeah yeah that he was ever I
think he was in France for a year wasn't
he on a on the GI Bill oh yes that I
think so yeah I'm not I'm not so yeah
I'm sorry I'm taking you away from you
no no not at all but I know that there
are letters
with them because help it figuring out
like places to stay in France or
vacation apartments and Paris so it is
it's such an unexpected connection
Norman Miller can I ask you a little
more about translation so Malachi
translated himself no he was Peter Grant
translated Peter Grant translated him
but there was actually a different
person who was supposed to originally
translate him and there's a really
extensive correspondence between him and
his translator and you see that Malachi
had a really amazing grasp on English he
was a really talented polyglot he knew
many we must have been very involved in
the translation he was and it's
interesting that the the things he you
know specifies to the translator
um his archives are at the Harry Ransom
Center I'm very excited fantastic
there's been all this work done recently
on the lives of translators and on
translator author relationships and this
sounds like really a good archive for
people working on that definitely it's a
really interesting correspondence yeah
yeah somebody is asking if the
conversation is going to be uh taped and
I think in Nessa said that it was going
to be taped let me see what she's
answering yes in a couple of weeks
people will be able to listen to this
conversation on uh listen to Julie's
lecture on on a recording which is great
because there was so much Rich textual
detail
and ways for us to go back and reread
these two writers so I just want to
thank you very much thank you so much
for the invitation